foreign
's lower house has appointed veteran
politician Juan Muhammad nomata leader
of a small party as the parliament
speaker
was the only name put forward a
compromise between the two biggest
parties move forward and Perth High it
doesn't matter how experienced or
qualified this person is the rift
between the two parties will not be gone
there will be more conflict over which
party you'll get what seat in the
cabinet
representatives and senators are
expected to hold a joint session later
this month to vote for prime minister
this is the man who could be the next
leader
Peter Lim jaronrad leads the move
forward party which won the most seats
in the general election in May
he needs 376 votes including 66 from the
mostly military-appointed Senate whose
members have so far voted in line with
military interests
at a nearby Temple there's a Taoist
Festival to celebrate the tiger Lord
Pita supporters are there to offer
prayers that he'll become Thailand's
next leader I think we'll have to wait
and see because I'm not confident in
these Senators because they don't like
our party from the bottom of my heart I
dislike the Senators I'm not sure about
the Senators votes but I think the
people's voices must come first the
upper house is not the only obstacle
Peter faces he's facing multiple legal
petitions including allegations he
violated election law by holding shares
in a media company
these cases were followed by Juan cry
likewatana a former senator who in 2008
filed another case which helped bring
down the then prime minister
Ruan cry says there's no political
agenda behind his petitions
on May 14th we voted for the MPS we did
not vote for the Prime Minister do not
think that by getting 14 million votes
and 156 seats means that you have the
consensus to BPM
that argument does not sit well with
Peter's supporters many say the election
results show that voters want change
after nine years of military-backed
government
but Thailand's history of disqualifying
politicians and disbanding pro-democracy
parties May mean an uphill battle for
Peter and more political uncertainty
ahead
Florence Louis Al Jazeera